oh oh pierre des erreurs non mais pas
vrai alors il y a une erreur il y a
juste une erreur
allons-y dites-moi je vous dis je vous
dis les erreurs
ça c'est pour nous mettre un peu la
pression
en parler c'est un des premiers films
que tu allais regarder tu avais été
choqué à la télé avec Maman et moi je
suis désolé mais il paraît que Florian
pleure devant certains films et même
devant gladiateur devant une tête de
ralenti
alors on assume ou pas
mais même moi j'avais oublié un point
pour moi ensuite
je ne suis pas attaché à ce film non non
nourriture aucun rapport avec ce film
non bah voyons ici au lit par exemple ou
coco pour Bigflo
c'est totalement vrai